An IDS can also be
deployed in an end host.
And such an IDS is a host-based IDS.
It can use a variety of
data on system activities.
For example,
most host-paced IDS use ptrace to obtain
the system calls made by the program to
monitor the behaviors of the program.
System called data is very
useful to security monitoring
because whenever a program requests
a resource such as memory allocation,
access to the file system, networks, and
IO devices, it needs to make a system
call to the operating system
because the operating system
manages the system resources.
That is, most of the interesting or
useful activities by program
are carried out through system calls.
For example if the users
browser receives a page with
a malicious JavaScript that is able to
break the protection in the browser and
attempts to overwrite
the Windows registry file,
the IDS will observe a write
system call to the registry file.
And can decide that this is an anomaly.